[Music]
rode all night stars Liam Neeson Joel
Kinnaman and Edie Harris in a movie
about really just a deadbeat dad he's a
drunk he's a criminal he's a murderer he
is not super duper superhero Superman he
is not the takin character the trailers
are leading you to believe this guy has
been beaten down by life and he has one
night to right the wrongs of his past
with his son who is on the run from Liam
Neeson's older best friend because some
people got killed and some lines got
crossed and now everything is coming to
a head in one night this is also
directed by the person who brought us
unknown which I liked obviously as well
as non-stop which I liked even more so
this is now his unofficial trilogy of
Liam Neeson films that have nothing to
do with each other and it is a way
better trilogy than the taken trilogy
has become and last year I didn't review
this film but I have since seen it and I
really like to walk among the tombstones
as well so the past two taken movies
have been disappointing but throughout
there he has what I call the perfect
rainy day thriller that he's been
releasing not to me a rainy day thriller
is a movie that is exciting it's fun you
watch it on a date when you have nothing
else to do you're bored maybe it comes
on TV it is the perfect type of
entertainment for that occasion
there are nowhere near as good a
thrillers as se7 but they're like the
perfect clear and present danger or
patriot games and run all night for me
was just that the trailers for this
movie will have you believe that it's
taken for similar to the trailer for a
walk among the tombstones which was
really just a quiet drama and a very
good one I thought run all night as I
said is a movie about a deadbeat dad
this is not an action movie per se yes
it is core it is definitely an action
movie but it's really more of a drama
thriller with mob ties and drug ties
there's a lot of things going on at
times there can be a little bit too much
going on but I would say that Liam
Neeson's waited performance the fact
that you really start to care for this
guy who has such deep regret for some of
the things he's done in the past with
his old criminal life and Joel Kinnaman
gives the best performance I've seen
from him because I thought he was fine
in Robocop but nothing special I really
liked his character in this movie for
his character as well as Neeson's and Ed
Harris I felt
a past I could feel like things had
happened to them before
that's good character build up that is a
good and interesting story when you can
envision characters existing before the
movie started I've said that before
those are the best types of characters
the ones you can actually imagine
existing beyond the movie as well as
before it they're not just these things
that help advance the plot along they're
actually people and these guys feel
lived in the performances I thought were
great another thing I loved about this
movie was the setting the fact that it
all takes place in the city at night in
one night you have this one night to
make everything right and so our heroes
never get a chance to rest neither do
our villains everyone's constantly
moving and this is an action movie plot
that makes action better but I like the
fact that Liam Neeson's character is not
super duper hero man he's actually a
very broken person it reminded me of how
edge of tomorrow was marketed everyone
was like oh Tom Cruise he's a big super
awesome guy and then he was actually a
coward and it made his character arc
awesome it's the same with this movie
none of the trailers lead you to believe
that Liam Neeson is really just a broken
old man in this movie and he sold it and
his arc was fantastic because of that in
regards to problems with the movie there
are a lot of different stories happening
at once there's cops there's drug
dealers
there's mob bosses there's Liam Neeson
and his son and then his family and
there's all this stuff happening and
there's even an assassin played by
common thrown in there and so at times
it can get a little bit jumbled but I
think they did the best they can to
really restrict it to the more important
aspects of it and I got to say common
was actually really good as that
assassin by the way also there's a cameo
by an actor I won't spoil it don't worry
it's so random it's like one scene and
it just didn't fit at all in fact the
story that he tells and the flashbacks
we get it felt like a completely
different movie in fact I did a little
research and apparently that actor had a
lot more scenes that they cut down from
the movie so I can tell they probably
were like you know this guy is not
really fitting in here we need to cut
this down besides that I had a great
time with run all night I think it is a
very fun thriller I think it has good
characters and there is a great scene
between Ed Harris and Liam Neeson at a
restaurant that was a very reminiscent
of the scene in heat with Robert De Niro
and Al
Pacino this is a suspenseful movie it
has good action sequences there's one
car chase with way too many cuts though
besides that it all looks good I think
this is probably the best film that this
director and Liam Neeson have made
together in regards to character
non-stop is probably the most
entertaining for just like fun summer
nothingness but this was probably his
best movie which makes sense because
this is their third collaboration
together and I'm looking forward to a
fourth if they ever decided to do that
I'm gonna give run all night a B+ don't
let the trailers make you think this is
taken for because it's not it's much
better than that so guys if you have
seen this movie I would be interested in
knowing what you thought and as always
thank you so much for watching guys I
really do appreciate it and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck man eyes
[Music]